today's latest story ben mulrooney good
morning canada
before we get into the show i want to
take a moment to speak to you about the
situation surrounding my wife jessica
and the next steps i will be taking with
belle media hold on what happened with
his wife jessica
so his wife got caught so basically
there's a activist was calling out
people for not using their platforms
and then supposedly his wife was
threatened
uh went after this black lives matter
and said some like i'm gonna fight you
or some
we don't know exactly but it sounds
dangerous and
she got outed she made a public apology
a lot of protesters went after her et
cetera et cetera if you don't know who
this guy is
his name is ben mulrooney he's the son
of brian mullen rooney brian
you don't know what a prime minister is
for all you uncultured americans
it's basically the substitute for a
president
for example justin trudeau your favorite
resident blackface artist
he's a prime minister i love
my wife however it is not my place to
speak for her
and today together we are committed to
doing the work to both
learn and understand more about
anti-black racism as well
as learn and understand more about our
blind spots so
what does this mean for me well it means
acknowledging here today
that my privilege has benefited me
greatly and while i have
certainly worked hard to build my career
i know that systemic racism and
injustice
helps people like me and harms those who
aren't like me often in ways
that are invisible to us this needs to
change
last saturday i watched on ctv as my
colleagues led a national conversation
about how we can take action
against systemic race and that
conversation showed me more than ever
we need more black voices more
indigenous voices more people of color
in the media as well as every other
profession and that is why i have
decided
to immediately step away from my role as
anchor at etoc
to create space for a new perspective
and a new voice
it is my hope that that new anchor is
black indigenous or a person of color
and they can use this important platform
to inspire
to lead and to make change i am so proud
of everyone involved with etoc and
indeed ctv
and i know they will continue to
demonstrate the excellence that has made
that show
and this network number one [ __ ] if you
don't get the
body with that bull so here's the real
problem you basically just announced to
the world that the person who's going to
replace you is a diversity hire
how do you think it's going to go for
that person when the viewers see that
how upset do you think they're going to
be
you've pretty much put them to the
wolves
first off so it's super stupid of you
because nobody likes a diversity higher
especially if you're a beloved figure
they're going to be mad that they're
seeing this person so really if you
think you're being benevolent
you're doing the exact opposite you're
doing a deserve a disservice to the
person
second thing nobody wants to be hired
because they're a person of color
or any other cringy ass term that you
want to use you don't want to be a
checkbox nobody wants to be a token okay
let's be real
nobody nobody nobody wants to be the
diversity
the affirmative action hire nobody wants
to be that ideally people
want to be hired because they're
competent and they're ready for the job
but this is not how you do it and you
certainly don't do it in public
that's awkward imagine being the person
hired and the only reason you're there
is because someone felt super guilty
cringe
i can guarantee you probably nobody
asked him to quit his job he just did
this as a pr stunt because of the
scandal of him and his wife
but it's super cringe i'm tired of it
nobody wants to see you on your knees
kissing feet know what he wants right
maybe there's like 10 15 black
no most of us don't want that no try to
go on the street
and go kiss them and they'll be like
what the [ __ ] what are you doing you put
one person there
what happened after that what happened
to and while i am no longer anchoring
e-talk i will continue to contribute to
the show
hosting red carpets and taking on other
special projects here at bell media so
let me get this straight you're gonna
continue working on ctv
but you're just not gonna do the job
that you probably didn't wanna do
and you're gonna make yourself look
great by being like oh i'm vacating my
job please hire a person of color
i didn't wanna do that job but you're
still gonna kindly do the best parts of
that job
is that what i'm understanding even if
you wanted to do that job
it doesn't change anything i still think
it's a bit cringe
i don't have the answer i don't know
what white people should do
but stepping down of you of your spot
hoping they're gonna do some so what do
you do what do you do if they take
something someone white
because at the spot when they did
interviews
they found something they found someone
white to do it that was that that could
fit the job
that person should step down as well
because that person has
white privilege and stuff like that
there's something i really find
weird about that it's the same thing as
people kissing feet
it's the same thing as like white people
shoe shining black folks to show their
apologies it's the same thing as self
flagellating to be like oh my god
i'm not like the other white folks who
want to hurt it's cringy
nobody cares about your virtual signal
it's not important
listen the biggest thing affecting black
folks is not race
it's class you really want to help
abandon your wealth
see if you're really about it but just
getting rid of your job get the [ __ ] out
of here
i hope that they then why did you make a
public announcement why did you just do
it in quiet oh you want to let everyone
know
that you're such a nice guy that you're
gonna allow someone else of a different
race
or of a different group no he's not
gonna allow he
hopes you know would have been more
relevant
if you used your platform to discuss
these issues if you care about them
to have these dialogues to have these
discussions but it's not by abdicating a
position in virtue signaling that you
make things better
this is a bad pr move it's gross and i
just find this kind of pandering on
national tv even cringier because i know
how many
checks and bounces it had to go through
how many producers had to see it do you
understand how many people at ctv have
to be tone deaf
to think that this is an okay statement
to make on tv like
how stupid does your production team
have to be to be like
we're doing such a good thing this is
why white liberals sometimes are some of
the most cringy people i've ever seen
because they don't know what to do
anymore
it's so cringy and it makes you seem
very dishonest and even more
untrustworthy ugh just oh
just ugh say it one more time oh like i
used this analogy last time but like yo
listen
if you're privileged you don't help
others by abdicating your privilege
if i have my full body and i see a guy
in a wheelchair and he's having a
struggle getting up some stairs or
whatever i'm not going to cut off my
legs to empathize with them
i'm going to help them with my position
it's so stupid
but aren't you going to feel better
without your legs now you guys are the
same
nah we're two people who can't get up
the stairs hey i feel you brother i
got legs too like what is it about like
the sons of prime ministers why they're
so cringey
big up big up the whole island massive
it's a boy chatna
coming straight from that golden globe
you're watching
me
the lack of struggle the lack of you
know the privilege that make you that
that i don't know what it is
i don't know i don't know what it is i
just want to stick him
chet hanks and justin trudeau in a room
and just see what kind of black music
they would make
he says imagine justice street
yes cringe man dude
oh wow
i can't try i can't i really can't
i won't do it pull it bullets gunshot
big up to you them i know i'm bad but
i'm trying to channel my this is not
good either
yeah yeah waguan
manic jerk chicken ah get the [ __ ] out
of here me like jerk chicken
you like jerk cause i'm a jerk
get in your poom poo yes sir show me the
lights
just give me the lights i don't know am
i doing good
are you guys cringed enough how you
doing preachy okay i mean
i'm cringing but less than when i was
watching ben maroon my man no eat no
puss
bad man suck nope batman
no no no no way
yeah we all know and just a last point
diversity for the sake of diversity
is uninteresting i don't want you to
stick a bunch of tokens up there
because you think it'll make you look
good when i want to be represented it's
not just a matter of race
sometimes there's a lot of white folks
who can represent my lived experiences
just as well or can really understand it
so when you stick a token there thinking
you're going to fix the issue it tells
me that you haven't really thought this
through
bobby caldwell okay bobby called was a
legend to this i would listen to this
music i'm like [ __ ]
sing that and then he popped out of the
darkness he's like surprised [ __ ] i was
like oh man
okay i didn't know you were gonna be
white but i still love this music you
know what i'm saying
it's not it's not because you stick a
black figure there that it's
going to fix anything if you put on the
uncle ruckus
sure he's black but let's put
the clueless girl stacy dash stacy dash
she got a dash
but yeah so it's just that's the last
point i wanted to make is this
it's corny nobody wants to be a checkbox
yeah yeah nobody wants that so
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below we want to hear
your thoughts on this what do you think
about the virtual signaling
[Music]
but if you think about it when they play
golf they have a caddy carry all their
oh yeah someone wipes their forehead
someone drives them around the field
basically comes at their beck and call
yeah and so if you think about that
yeah how are the athletes they barely
have to you know
are they like uh tennis as well yeah
yeah
i always thought it was funny that like
tiger woods has the most masters wins
you know i mean just because like in a
sports full of white tooth the black guy
is the best master
i always like that skye reminds me of
trudeau when he speaks
well he's the son of the prime yeah but
this just seems like a political dress
trudeau would do it's just really
it's just it's similar it is very it's
like the same thing whether you're
the prime or the prez or the ceo
yeah or the host or the it's
pretty much the same thing you are the
figure
of something bigger right but you are
the representative
of that so whenever you're gonna suck or
you're gonna take the platform to speak
there's gonna be there's gonna be
similarities of course